the people of New York City finally you
know you inject them with stuff you lock
them in their buildings all that stuff
okay but you come for their Pizza they
have just about had it with um efforts
uh here is a New York City conservative
artist his name is Scott lobato and he
went to City Hall with some pizza to
show his disgust
ing
the woke ass idiots who run this city
are doing everything in their power to
destroy it we have naked men with their
titties bouncing around all over the
city yesterday in public in front of
children
we have the most violent raging crime
rate ever we are being invaded by
illegal immigrants who are being treated
way better than our homeless veterans
our teachers and first respond to Heroes
who were fired still not compensated
because they didn't take the bouncy
injection our city schools produce the
dumbest kids and the woke ass punks who
run New York City are afraid of pizza
the world used to respect New Yorkers as
tough thick-skinned and gritty now we
have become pussified it's a damn shame
you heard of the Boston Tea Party
well this is the Boston New York this is
the New York pizza party
give us pizza or give us death
give us pizza
or give us death
give us pizza for give us death
destroying every small business
that's what this city keeps doing
can't have a small business
can't have pizza
New York City is nothing without Pizza
the Boston Tea Party this is the New
York pizza party
man is there anything better like than a
New York Italian accent and just the
attitude of all that and that's what
they're trying to kill these idiots he's
right over the weekend it was Pride
weekend you've got people in dog masks
twerking in front of four-year-olds and
that we tell everybody how great that is
but you want to look at that delicious
wasted Pizza like we don't have great
pizza in Miami like that I mean I gotta
tell you you know I don't uh complain
about Florida over here but we could use
some of that we got our fancy Mr o1 in
Coconut Grove I know but we don't have
that awesome New York style pizza but
people have just had it they have just
had it I'm pretty sure that that guy
like he didn't wake up that morning like
you know I'm gonna toss some pizza over
and over the fence at City Hall but
that's what these morons these mental
midgets like mayor Eric Adams have
pushed these people into doing
[Music]
thank you
foreign
[Music]